[Music]
sure being here ty thanks for having me
back I'm really excited to be back
primarily because I wanted to ask your
question which is why are you so ashamed
of having been on Star Trek what you
said I was you think I was on Star Trek
well you were on Star Trek I don't think
yeah yeah you were I don't think great
lengths to cover up your identity you
can't find it on IMDB or Wikipedia but
it's it actually it was actually a very
popular show I don't know if you know
that wait your fans would love to know
that you were on star you're saying that
I cuz I did some stuff before I did this
show but I don't think I ever did Star
Trek you have a clip here
roll clip is it wise to press him on
this I am the negotiator
Karnas will have to cooperate with me
and the terrorists and damage
sensitivities and may I suggest a secure
Channel Admiral a sensible precaution
make it so yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I was the guy with the stupid hair in
Star Trek next generation well where did
you find that a friend of mine sent it
to me I just loved that it looked as if
you had covered your face yeah and you
use the terrible I don't know if you
could hear that voice but it was the
worst that's my actual working for a
creepy space guy voice when I'm not
being Conan O'Brien yeah
after the show's over and I go back to
being chip Whitley the actor who plays
Conan O'Brien that's my real voice yeah
enough about me let's talk about you a
little bit but then get back to me okay
great you know that deal you know how
yeah let's talk about your family you
have a family loves you
[Laughter]
everybody know you have how many kids
you have you have two kids at two
dollars two daughters two and a half
year old essentially I don't really keep
track and then there's some kids out
there or so I'm told or some I don't
know about no Anna and a nine month old
well okay what's how about the one who's
two and a half do you have any idea that
you are on television as she's she she
has she seen me twice on television once
was about a year or so ago and I may
have even told the story her but it was
basically I was on Sesame Street and I
was performing with Abby Cadabby and I
got really cocky and brought her out to
watch me performing that we could
everything she was gonna freak out and
then all she did was go I never
mentioned me at all that her father was
with a D yeah so cut to about two weeks
ago my wife was like you know we haven't
really done this since then so she put
on an episode of Modern Family and just
sat next to our daughter and our
daughter in the middle of one of my
scenes did something that she has never
done in her life and hasn't done sense
which is asked to go to bed no child
asks to go to ever never it's a fate
worse than death
that she
I'm ready for bed let's do this I'm
exhausted from this terrible terrible
performance you get Matthew Broderick
terrific actor and a guy who's been on
our show millions of times guest-starred
on the show and you guys had have quite
an intimate scene I made out with Ferris
Bueller I felt like I was making out
with all kinds of classic like iconic TV
and film and stage stars at one time
yeah yeah because he's done so much his
body of work is so great let's I think
we have a still from that adventure you
to add then that's the most erotic photo
I've ever seen babe that's right after
our nipples kissed they really hit it
off your nipples hit it off oh yeah they
still talk sometimes you eat late at
night you hear your nipple talking you
gotta let it go see the glow of the
cellphone
[Laughter]